et
[Musique]
on a toujours rêvé de devenir samouraï
seul problème c'est un chien les
chouettes samouraï des cas chez moi
c'est un peu rattrapé
on dirait que tu as besoin d'un
professeur presse que je perds retrouver
un
défouloir
n'irai pas un bouquin pour apprendre à
devenir samouraï qui pensent à samouraïs
pour les nounous et non parce que ce
serait pour des nuls kramer kariger
achats retombe toujours sur ses pattes
sais pas si je vous ai dit mais je suis
pas chaud
on peut passer directement au moment où
je te fais un bon ben moi c'est
maintenant que je préfère
qu'il faut qu'ils protègent au nom de la
loi je t'arrête
par le réalisateur du roi lion et lui
rappeler
non d'un caniche constipé qu'est ce qui
se passe ici le 12 octobre ça va barder
plus
largement
comment on fait pour entrer maintenant
bon faisons réessayer
et voilà le travail le film le plus fun
des vacances
la peur n'existe que dans ton esprit et
un petit peu aussi dans mon kimono
samouraï académie qui aurait cru qu'une
armée de chats aimerait autant les
flageolets
on
n'est pas rendus au cinéma le 12 octobre